[Music]  i've been  dreaming  every night  the same  nightmare  stranger  the fate of the multiverse  depends on us  careful stephen  this path exacts a heavy tall  [Music]  okay  marvel studios dr strange in the  multiverse of madness holding beaters  may 6th as it gets on sale now  the multiverse  [Music]  it's life or death  you could use an avenger  there are other avengers we'll get you  back on the lunch box  the fate of the multiverse  depends on us  no pressure  strange in the multiverse of madness  tickets on sale this wednesday i did  what i had to do  to protect our world  you break the rules and become a hero  [Music]  i do it and i become the enemy  wanda  what do you know about the multiverse  [Music]  you